what a great day
good Morning Captain good morning
Captain for you maybe will you get a
haircut yes sir
we welcome you back to CBS mornings you
know that that's a beloved hit you've
seen that show The Love Boat you can't
say the love boat without saying what
Nate
soon you'll be making another run
I'll go from the 70s and 80s now it's
coming back as a reality dating show
what husband and wife Jerry O'Connell
and Rebecca Romaine are the host of The
Real Love Boat right here on CBS so this
new show this is how it works it brings
real life singles together so look for
Love on a Princess cruise ship go
princess if you remember characters in
the original also find love on a luxury
cruise ship the ship's crew played a
really big role in the matchmaking the
same holds true this time around here's
a look at Jerry and Rebecca in action on
the show
when I met Rebecca yeah I know you hear
like love at first sight I just enjoyed
her energy so much immediately yeah I
think we both decided we wanted to be
with each other more than anybody else
in the whole world
look that's what we're looking for here
like a connection so here's how it works
at each Port either the men or the women
will be in control first it's the women
[Music]
I like that part Jerry and Rebecca join
us in the steel hello Mr and Mrs
O'Connell I love you Jerry going you
know I was just drawn to her energy
Romaine did you see her
yeah
you know me I don't judge people
physically
if you live in L.A it's about people's
auras it's about their energies and you
know what I'm getting the great energy
here
[Applause]
Rebecca I've heard you describe this
getting this gig is it was like a dream
come true because there's so much
Nostalgia attached for us as children of
the 80s we watched the original series
we watched in reruns in fact while we
were shooting the show on the ship they
had the original show in reruns and we
watched it non-stop it's it was such a
fun show back then it still is and we're
really trying to capture that Nostalgia
from the original show which was about
people finding a second chance at love
and our singles on the show are all real
people they're teachers and we've got a
nurse who's got a firefighter we've got
a couple teachers I think everybody on
that show has great energy they all have
great energy I'm talking about they're
all drop dead gorgeous all of them you
know what is really fun for us as well
we watch uh probably an unhealthy amount
of reality or if we want to get fancy
unscripted television so to get to host
one was like I mean normally we're just
in our under I'm in my underwear
watching at home yelling at the screen
yelling at Jeff Probst but it was it was
just so much fun to be so Jerry kept
getting in trouble because Jerry was
getting very emotionally involved with
our singles and there is an elimination
ceremony at the end of every episode
where somebody gets left behind at the
Port somebody who's not picked and the
first time we made that announcement
Jerry went no and the all the producers
came out and said Jerry you have to
remain
neutralizer yes
but we should we should give people a
little bit more detail on the game as
it's played on the boat right so you get
to Port it's beautiful you're in like
eight or nine locations uh and then
there's a couple's match where everyone
pairs off and then there's a competition
where they have to work together right
yes so all their
we have these we call it a dating
Adventure Show we're on after Survivor
before The Amazing Race our locations
are stunning so we for example they have
to climb the Rock of Gibraltar and get
to the top uh they've got in Marseille
we were in Lavender Fields at this
beautiful old soap making company where
they had to run through Lavender Fields
and then soap each other down and find a
coin on the inside of a bar of soap and
we were in Sicily and these Olive Groves
the olive oil
gorgeous gorgeous locations really it
looked like you had the whole boat to
yourself when I was watching no it's an
operating so there's other passengers on
the boat passengers
yeah I mean we were only allowed to
shoot where um you know the guests
didn't have a bingo game going on or
right or some sort of event I I do want
to say this was
um our first cruise ever and we're
Cruisers now um
welcome to the club
I didn't know what to expect and it was
it was such a dream and also I had never
personally never been to Italy I had
never been to Greece and when you're on
a cruise you get to go to one of these
spots I understand Jack and Rose no I
get I get it
we were we were very romantic about you
know Finding Love on a ship and you just
you don't have to unpack your stuff too
right and leave it there and go to
different places there's a euphoric
villain when you're on a cruise or
something in the air traveling to
beautiful places the food is great
you're with someone you love
um it seems like the dream job now you
guys have worked together on different
projects but Rebecca you said this time
it was a little different why why so why
was it different this time
um Well we I'm sure we we were in the
same quarters they were always together
like literally always together but you
know what we I don't know if it was the
vibe of the Real Love Boat we got into a
minimal amount of fights I mean
shockingly
shocking well normally if we were on
land we were spending this much time
with each other it would be one to one
and a half bites a day we've been
married now for 15. we've been together
for 18 years
Jerry makes me really really really
happy but he also really makes me mad
sometimes but it's it's you know how to
push each other's buttons which we
bounce back from the fights we actually
you know we used to let things linger a
little longer I think now at this point
we're like we can let it go really
easily you see this funny at home
because this is what he does not always
what's your idea of a dream date guys oh
you know what Sheriff does the best
thing Jerry surprises me with surprise
dates and he really takes into
consideration the type of music I like
or the kind of movie I want to see and
he'll take me for example to a movie but
he won't tell me what we're going to see
he'll make me stand on the sidewalk
while he gets the tickets and like
literally not look at the movie poster
while we go in and I have to figure out
what the movie is based on okay Jerry
are you taking notes over here I didn't
tell Rebecca we were going to see
Pentatonix last week
I love the surprise surprise they're
very thought he puts so much thought and
what do you do Rebecca I just enjoy the
surprise
come on
here Rebecca that's right we have a good
time we still have fun it's I mean it's
Rebecca stays married to me thank you
baby I really appreciate that I'm very
O'Connell Rebecca Romaine thank you so
much for joining us guys thank you thank
you for everything all right the real
love
Eastern on CBS and available to stream
on Paramount plus gotta check it out